ich muss es zugeben jetzt wird hässlich
freunde deutschland diskutiert immer
noch aufgeregt über hass und hetze im
netz und was der staat da vielleicht
doch mal gegen machen könnte anders
jahres ist natürlich der fall
renate künast denn das urteil eines
berliner gerichts da neulich heißt ja
nichts anderes als sie dürfen die braut
jetzt küssen übersetzt übersetzt
systematisch organisierte hass soll
offensichtlich menschen davon abhalten
sich noch zu engagieren
heutzutage braucht man in diesem land ja
echte nehmerqualitäten servus
warzenschwein man muss ja nun echt
fragen wer ihnen ins gehirn geschossen
hat dumm wie die sau die alte wenn sie
mit schwarzem und moslem sex haben
wollen bitte nur zu fick dich for future
führer befiehl wir folgen oder
hämorriden am arsch der systemmedien
entschuldigung hämorriden am arsch der
systemmedien da steht immer noch auf
meiner visitenkarte
inzwischen ist das internet so eine art
werden sie auch gemerkt haben geistiges
mallorca also ein ort wo man sich
benehmen kann wie die letzte wildsau
dabei ist das theoretisch gar kein
rechtsfreier raum was tun ist die frage
teil des problems sind natürlich
facebook und co ja die sind laut
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz eigentlich
verpflichtet toast mit morddrohungen
oder volksverhetzung zu löschen
wer aber schon mal im internet war weiß
das klappt nicht so richtig so und jetzt
hat er unsere justizministerin frau
lamprecht folgende idee wie wäre es denn
wenn die großen konzerne die das mit dem
löschen show nicht hinkriegen auch noch
was anderes nicht hinkriegen würden
ich will die plattform betreiber
verpflichten offizialdelikte also solche
taten bild zum beispiel volksverhetzung
oder mord bedrohungen dass diese an die
ermittlungsbehörden gemeldet werden
müssen ja sie sollen ihre eigenen kunden
anzeigen so als auch eine dönerbude ihr
eigenes gammelfleisch melden muss es
wird nicht passieren
im übrigen ist es doch ureigenste
aufgabe des staates geltendes recht
durchzusetzen
das kann ich doch nicht an private
firmen delegieren da braucht es mehr
staatsanwälte mehr richter feiert
facebook kann das jedenfalls nicht
leisten
die künstliche intelligenz die bei denen
löscht ist ja jetzt schon völlig
überfordert dieses unternehmen kann mit
software nackte frauen aus ölgemälden
erkennt oder pamela an statue
aber sobald jemand schreibt stirb du
[ __ ] ist der algorithmus leider
überfordert ja das stimmt
das stimmt interessant wäre mal
folgendes experiment ich poste eine
nackte statue aber auf den pimmel
schreibe ich ganz klein
[ __ ] weißt du doch rhythmus nicht
mehr warum soll ja machen sie das mal
als anregung machen wir alle heute haben
kurz gesagt die idee von christine
lambrecht geht leider in die falsche
richtung
womit ich jetzt nicht sagen will die
groko macht gar nichts gegen hass im
netz also die machen schon was
[Musik]
die bundesregierung informiert gegen
hass und hetze im netz haben wir die
perfekte waffe unfassbar langsames
internet versucht auch mal andere bei
twitter als dummes stück chance zu
beschimpfen im funkloch ab
außerdem fördern wir seit jahren
konsequent den lehrermangel damit
irgendwann kein jugendlicher mehr weiß
wie man fonds scheint ihre
bundesregierung
[Musik]
ach ja
ich frage mich gerade hemmungsloser hass
im netz gibt es dagegen nicht auch was
von ratiopharm
es wäre schön ich finds schön laut laut
bundeskriminalamt kommen 92 prozent der
hetze im internet von rechts also quasi
nach dem motto zwei hitler und wie wir
spätestens seit der ermordung von walter
lübke wissen digitaler hass hat manchmal
auch schreckliche folgen in der analogen
realität und selbst nach dem mord an
lübke konnte war noch vor kurzem unter
einem facebook video ekelhafte
kommentare lesen wie monatelang eben
nicht gelöscht wurden
trotzdem sollen die sozialen netzwerke
vielleicht solche fonds direkt den
ermittlungsbehörden melden wie finden
die ermittlungsbehörden das denn so ich
leite die frage mal weiter an alexander
wipprecht er als staatsanwalt eine
abteilung gegen hate speech leitet sowie
und wir finden es voll sowie die idee
von der frau lambrecht man endlich
kriegen wir mal was zu tun allein
youtube hat im ersten halbjahr 300.000
inhalte gemeldet volksverhetzung
holocaust leugnungen beleidigung wenn
nur ein bruchteil davon zur anzeige
kommt können wir den ganzen lande dicht
machen
wer soll das hier alles bearbeiten und
mit welcher technik hin
der kollege heinz der versuch zwei tagen
seinen rechner ans internet
anzuschließen so eine scheiße und
schreibmaschine läuft auf windows 8 9
in der praxis ist das nämlich alles
nicht so einfach
obwohl hört meinungsfreiheit auf und wo
fängt beleidigung an
schauen sie sich doch mal ihre eigene
heute-show facebook-seite an hier ein
original fettpolster schreibt henzelmann
scheck über sie herr welke was für ein
widerlicher schleim bolzen dieser fed
gefressene system nicht jedes berliner
gericht würde sagen viel höflicher kann
man eigentlich nicht formulieren
oder wo elf der richtet seine
sachbezogene kritik als komplette heute
show theme und schreibt ihren losen
bastarde ihr arbeitet nur viermal im
jahr und dann noch nur halbe stunde ihr
[ __ ] da muss ich ehrlicherweise
zugeben da stimmt alles außer [ __ ]
ehrlose bastarde kann ich komplett
unterschreiben alexander weiß mutmaßt
welche es vielleicht einer jener
menschen die ein beispiel dafür sind
dass ihre mutter korrekt hätte abtreiben
sollen anstatt durch exzessiven
alkoholkonsum eine abordnung selber
herbeizuführen zu versuchen
ja das klingt jetzt hart aber was soll
ich da machen als staatsanwalt ich meine
ich kenne ihre mutter nicht das müssen
also das internet bleibt wilder westen
wir versuchen ja alles aber wie sollte
ich zum beispiel ein konzern wie
facebook dazu bringen mir die daten von
so hetzern zu gehen
ich kann ihn nicht zwingen ich meine die
sind facebook und ich bin nur der staat
die müssen wir gar nichts sagen
die deutsche chef lobbyistin wird
gefragt wie viele menschen sich bei
facebook um hass kommentare kümmern die
die frage ist dann wir kriegen diese
frage häufig aber es ist tatsächlich
auch so dass es sehr schwierig ist
darauf eine antwort zu geben die
zufriedenstellende
das mag jetzt auch mal so wenn meine
frau fragt bist du fremdgegangen sagte
schatz die frage die sich häufig es ist
allerdings schwierig eine antwort darauf
zu finden die zufriedenstellend ist
wir geben nicht auf was wir allerdings
zugeben muss ist wenn man den ganzen tag
dieser hass mails liest das macht schon
was mit einem so machen zweier ein
gewisser alles klar heinz wichtig
alexander war damals michael beschreibt
auf facebook wilke du bist der letzte
arsch nur große fresse ich möchte ich
mal sehen wenn es hart auf hart kommt
dann schaust du dir in die hose warte ab
ein sprichwort sagt man trifft sich
immer zweimal im leben mach weiter so
mit einer großen fresse wie können
warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zweiter oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren